hi sisters James Charles here and today
I'm at BuzzFeed and I got to play with
some puppies while answering a ton of
your sisters questions and I've never
been more excited for anything in my
entire life oh I would probably have to
say my brand-new I shot of hell that I
just release with morphe at the team
trials eyeshadow palette literally
formulated it so there's every single
color and there to create any luck so
it's pretty much like my go-to at this
point hi sister started about two years
ago no I believe oh it is two years now
oh my god lovely - your sister verse sri
i was actually a halloween and my best
friend's father was helping me cuz i was
a dr two years ago and I used to have
disgusting hair like the grossest hair
in the entire what does a man bun thank
God that pays my life is over and I
would always wear baseball hats because
it was so ratty thank you that I yes I
agree
that I knew it needed to be covered like
I could not go out in public looking
like that absolutely not so my friend's
dad helped me like cut holes in a
baseball hat so I could fit my deer
antlers through it
so I could be a deer and cover the hair
at the same time and for some reason
when he gave it to me I was like thanks
sister Marco and for some reason that it
just stuck and my best friend's group
chat all started calling each other
sister and then when it came time to
naming the fandom I hated the word fan
disgusting so I thought the sisters
would be perfect since I already called
on my best friend and sister that I
should just make everybody my best
friends and just welcome them to the
family Beauty for me as a hobby but what
I'm really passionate about in gonna is
business I love marketing I love numbers
and I love shattered eyes day in
consulting with major brands so I feel
like I'd be running a major business in
the beauty space makeup and also music
for me is a huge side passion that I
would like to take more seriously in the
future
I literally fell into makeup by accident
about three years ago now and I was
always just in love with like art and I
used to do girls hair for my school just
for funsies and like a little side
hustle while I was still in school every
day just cuz I really liked making
people feel beautiful and just like the
beauty space in general I'd always want
to youtube tutorials on it so so the
people that inspired me have been making
tutorials and Jacqueline Hale who are
really great friends why now which is
just so crazy that in the course of
three years I went from like being their
number one fans and now like working at
them all the time and talking to them
and just like sharing our love for
makeup together which is so cool I would
probably have to say Demi just because
she's like my one my biggest role models
and literally one of the most talented
musicians ever our makeup artists
already does such a beautiful job I love
Jail but Demi definitely does rock like
natural makeup very very often so I
really want to give her like full-on at
James Charles colorful glam just for fun
like a little insert and picture well
there are YouTube video brushes oh I
have a lot of brushes I have like three
entire tubs probably a thousand at this
point I don't even know my favorite
shape of the entire palette probably has
to be the bright red which is called ear
Koenig just because I have always wanted
like a vibrant true red in my collection
since I started makeup a few years ago
and I feel like red is a very very hard
cause ah to formulate all the names in
the palette or things that I either say
on like a very very frequent basis or
named after important people or places
or things in my life after formulating
the red with the lab back and forth and
back and forth probably literally six or
seven times when I finally swatch the
final I literally looked at everyone I
was like you're kidding whenever I was
traveling or doing photo shoots on set I
would always notice that I'd have to
bring so many different palettes and
products and glitters and highlighters
and everything to create whatever look I
was going for especially if I didn't
know going into it so I always knew that
if I wanted to create one product it
would be a palette that I could bring
with me on set or just have my makeup
kit to literally be able to create any
love so literally one night I saw in
Photoshop and just played for hours and
hours
and just arranging all the colors in
different formats and I literally came
up with a palette before I was even
asked to do one so I was like putting it
into the universe you don't vary that
and when I got asked I literally sent
them the PSD file that night and was
like we're gonna make this and they're
like okay sounds good
I guess like the palette would be like
my favorite moment so far it sold out
twice now worldwide which is like I
literally cannot even believe it like I
could just cry thinking about it just to
like put it out into the world was
already exciting enough because I lit it
it was like giving birth and a weird way
uh you know that sounds so weird but
like it's true like it was my baby my
favorite skincare products are taught
not sponsored but would love that please
email me I take my makeup just using
makeup lights every single night but
then I'm super super careful to wash my
face very very well with I can makeup
removing oil just make sure that the
products don't get stuff there
especially when you're taking on
literally 800 pounds and then once it's
off I just moisturize if I had to pick
one color to wear for the rest of my
life I would probably say a gold color
as boring as that sounds
just because as much as I love playing
with color I really like switching up my
looks
a go-to gold would be perfect if I can
just like put it on the middle of the
lid the inner corner and the brow bone
for a really really beautiful and not to
look kind of like the one I'm wearing
today but just maybe a little bit more
intense I think my biggest piece of
advice for anybody who wants to join the
YouTube space or be in the beauty
community is by whatever talent that
whatever makes you unique and really
ride off of that to make it you have to
work so incredibly hard and you have to
really set yourself apart from everybody
else so trying to do this same exact
thing I would definitely say that once I
started focusing more towards
entertainment based content and really
doing the crazy creative books that I
love and I'm truly passionate about is
when people started to tune in so I
would definitely say like you have to be
unique if you want to make it in the
space I got into a lot of drama when I
first heard it in the beauty community
because I wasn't really growing that
fast and I was also better at some other
people who were like ahead of me at the
time I wish I could tell myself like to
focus on yourself and to stop worrying
about other people what they're saying
about you what they're doing what videos
they're doing like I wish I would have
just like focus on myself and minded my
own
I'm really rated that now queena staying
out of drama but back then a little bit
rough all the pups were provided to us
today by Vanderpump dogs here in LA and
they are literally so durable I'm
excited to be checking out because me
and my little brother are actually
talking about adopting a puppy but if
you want to learn more about how you can
adopt you can check out Vanderpump dogs
org
[Music]
[Music]